lo que acaba de dibujar aquí es una
curva inversa del futuro del petróleo es
cuando la curva de los precios futuros
se ve así significa que es mucho más
caro comprar petróleo hoy que el acordar
comprar petróleo en el futuro dentro de
dos meses dentro de cuatro meses o
dentro de ocho meses y existen un par de
razones por la que esto podría ocurrir
la razón más común es que posiblemente
en este momento haya escasez de petróleo
por cualquier razón que sea va a lo
mejor si está en guerra y se necesita
consumir más de este combustible para
esas máquinas locas que utilizan en el
ejército o quizás hay escasez porque se
está perdiendo petróleo es la cuestión
es que algo está causando escasez y hace
que la gente esté de acuerdo en pagar
esta cantidad actualmente por el
petróleo la otra razón por la que
podrían tener ese tipo de comportamiento
en los precios y de hecho tiene que ver
con lo que queremos aprender en este
vídeo es que las personas en el futuro
esperan que el precio del petróleo no
sea muy diferente al precio actual si
ustedes pudieran ir y preguntarle a
todas las personas que podrían ser
compradores o vendedores de petróleo
esto es imposible pero imagina no sé que
ustedes lo pudieran hacer y ustedes les
preguntarán cuál es el precio esperado
del petróleo en 8 meses ellos podrían
decir bueno yo creo que aunque edita
tenemos algo de escasez nos vamos a
recuperar más adelante por lo que
esperamos que el precio en el futuro sea
de 100 dólares si todos esperarán que
este precio en 8 meses sea de 100
dólares porque es que algunas personas
en el futuro estarían dispuestas a
vender el petróleo a 50 dólares porque
estarían de acuerdo en venderlo por
debajo del precio esperado y la razón
por la que esto podría suceder es que
quizás son productores de petróleo y ya
que ellos dependen de los ingresos del
petróleo para mantener a las personas
que trabajan para ellos ellos para poder
garantizar el precio y evitar que sea
muy volátil están dispuestos a venderlo
con un descuento sobre este precio
futuro esperado
esta es una cosa que puede llevar a ese
comportamiento en el precio futuro del
petróleo
normalmente cuando las personas ven ese
tipo de comportamiento este tipo de
curva es muy común que usen el término
de mercado invertido dicen que este
mercado futuro es un mercado invertido
mercado invertido y lo que quiero
aclarar aquí es que eso es lo que dice
la mayoría de las personas pero no es
exactamente lo que significa este
término si es que queremos dar la
definición académica precisa la
definición precisa no es una curva
invertida la definición se le llama
teoría de mercado invertido normal
significa que los vendedores están de
acuerdo en vender el precio futuro con
un descuento con respecto al precio
esperado debido a la volatibilidad y así
pueden asegurar sus precios así que la
teoría del mercado inverso es en
realidad este fenómeno de acá pero esto
realmente no es observable pues no
pueden ir a preguntarle a todas las
personas que compran o venden el
petróleo cuál va a ser el precio
esperado el precio está acá y vemos la
curva invertida del precio futuro y por
eso se llama mercado invertido
una forma en la que ustedes más humanos
pueden observar esto es que si ven esto
nuestro precio de contado y nos vamos
moviendo en el tiempo por lo que vemos
que esta presión no está cambiando mucho
y debido a esto
estos precios futuros más baratos
conforme nos vamos acercando a la fecha
de la venta tienen que llegar a este
punto del precio conforme éste comienza
75 y conforme nos vamos a dejarlo en el
tiempo éste va a converger al punto del
precio de contado en esos meses así que
cuando ustedes ven los precios futuros
que van aumentando hacia el precio de
contado durante el tiempo conforme se
van acercando a su fecha de entrega esta
es la forma en la que se puede observar
que se tiene un mercado invertido